you tube de squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur free c'est par le même mec
qui après le jeu un time le jeu on était
dans la prison là où j'étais une énorme
victimes voilà c'est parti playes
on va faire un petit match d'exhibition
qui puis-je prendre jeolla lui me plaît
bien il a un masque et des mecs de star
wars
sauf qu'il n'est pas blanc il est il est
un peu style à base de minerais voilà
donc cet homme est un mineur conclusion
de berne
oh mon dieu alors on y va on part sur
lui comment je fais voilà très bien
aulas lacombe stallone allez allez on y
va donc déjà la différence de style
assez énorme entre ces deux personnages
d'un fait ou alors faisons ya des petits
fridge suis désolé bon c'est pas de ma
faute
donc ça c'est mon adversaire qui rentre
au premier qu'est-ce qui varient ce
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi hier
entre eux et ça c'est moi
ouais je suis déjà tombée watts
c'est une blague sait où on va aller je
veux plus faire de combats médiévaux
lève toi mon gars au caire mais son
masque en mode en mode il est chaud pour
attaquer mon post fight allez c'est
parti
non non je veux je veux pas abandonner
je comprends rien je martèle toutes les
touches watts
c'est totalement impossible si l'autre
passant maintenant mais mon gars ah
ouais je suis très fair play c'est à
dire quand je joue je fais voilà à
badens ça marche pas du coup je choisis
de mandales et alors ce soir d'assister
à rhisnes qui ne sert à rien voilà dans
le ring on peut observer une poule
voilà tiens et là moi je vais taper les
arbitres illoul arbitres on va taper la
vie de contrats qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'arbitré mais carrément me défoncer
allez olla scandaleux scandaleux à
redire et danseuse étoile quoi qu alain
sebbah white les saumons aller voila
voila moi je m'en vais de l'autre côté
et s'usent moins stallone voilà repose
sa très bien maintenant ont pu y
retourner
tiens qu'est-ce qui fait que je suis
confus up hockey et celle du père kyoto
à attention stallone en mode danseuse
étoile n'a commencé que sir redouté
habib tad watts non je veux faire des
enfants je veux faire les enfants
stallone alors si tu veux pas faire
c'est ton problème tu me tapes pas les
tactiques
voilà c'est comme ça que vous faire
attendez j'ai trouvé la technique en
mode wide d'accord très
rien eu voilà le visage de la honte
non mais regardez le très bien il
passait l'aspirateur avec mon corps là
et laisser bois et toile arbitres
moustachu l'ap que tu m'aides pas parce
qu'il ya une bonne assise dans le public
et c'est incroyable ce qui se passe à
l'écran je mens vit discrètement persian
aimer voyager si je passe incognito il
me voit pas déshonoré or attend d ôter
un truc emmerdes câlin à non non non en
fait on a dit que pas déguiser voilà pas
l'idéal est au top alors voit sa vie qui
descend en haut mais ce qu'un jour il va
mon ordi vient de cracher très bien bon
du coup va se faire un autre match
d'exhibition on va changer de catcheur
aux joues un squelette et on est contre
un travesti du nom de lola qui a su tia
gorge water allez c'est parti on y va
christophe collette
olalala et bat et là qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait qu'aller au est ce qu'on fait de
la grosse botte
il ya des rangs des positions qu'ils
sont mais improbable jamais vu ça de
toute ma vie lola au galop j'ai un petit
nom de cheval sur un poney à les lola au
galop mais au regard des airs à l'aide
des trucs de plus en plus gros gain
tiens tiens tu vas y ça fait un peu
bizarre ça fait un peu razmoket quand il
marche comme ça un version squelette
travers nos caisses qui va faire été un
carton cassé lui carton c'est ridicule
quoi watts
ok alors cet homme devrait travailler
carrément chez ikea c'est un peu le grog
carrière devant lui
et maintenant voici pour rogers fort ce
rouge contre un cinquantenaire
alcoolique qui se trouvait au bar du
cours mais regardez lauder on dirait
qu'il est en train d'essayer de vendre
des tapis à quelqu'un quoi plutôt que de
compter de compter le score et voilà et
l'autre qui revend ses tapis là tu peux
pas compter et dire qu'il a perdu non à
la solution ultime quoi c'est lui c'est
quoi ton petit nom propre je ne serai
pas décrire cette position actuellement
fait du oui à j'ai trouvé watts ce qui
l'a fait cet homme aussi magnifique
coûté phone
attendez je vais le lâcher ça on va y
aller à la page facebook ici tonnes d'or
d'ailleurs fait du moins une souris
verte qui courait dans l'herbe qui va
partir sur un coup de chaise
apparemment c'est juste pour apporter en
fait t'as vu j'ai une chaise pas toi je
pèse et voilà le combat des hommes les
plus blasés de la planète c'est
maintenant ça se passe tout d'accord ok
par tous pour toi que je voulais taper
chez leur bétail par comme ça mais
pourquoi ils taperont meurtre au ballet
opt in a pris la dynamique le mec et moi
je propose pour contrer sa dynamique une
fourchette
allez allez on y va on se mange tout de
suite est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
exploser a dit attends j'arrive pour
t'aider à rentrer d'accord donc j'étais
j'ai été une sorte de ballon
rebondissant dans l'autre il s'est pris
pour poetry
what oh oui alors assure une partie de
quidditch eric ainsi potter maintenant
ouais ça parents quidditch et voilà les
gens c'est déjà fini j'espère que ça
vous aura plu oui je fais pas des vidéos
plus longue sur un jeu comme ça parce
qu'après je trouve que c'est lassant et
je suis regardé mais vous inquiétez pas
à des vidéos plus l'on voit arriver
merci de regarder mais l'idée de
m'éviter vie des vidéos vous êtes top
comme j'ai tout le temps et puis on va
se faire cette fois un tchèque du front
à l'est stratégique du front bennoo
ridicule web m6 web qui suis je sais
jouer de la flûte
je souhaite du ballon
j'vais plein de trucs les jambes fait
c'est jouer notre excuses demandées